the shadow former rail mr. Jonathan
Reynolds mr. Reynolds thank you for
joining us why did you resign well let
me say the start I like Jeremy
personally a great deal i enjoyed the
work I did with him but one of the
reasons I think Jeremy is quite popular
within the labor movement is these
authentic he's true to what he believes
in and so I think if you're a shadow
minister and you want to be authentic
and true to what you believe in and you
have some real doubts about the course
that we've taken and I thought
particularly with the sacking of Pat
McFadden late last night that was the
wrong decision to make for that for the
wrong reasons if on principle as I did I
didn't agree with that decision I think
the honorable thing to do is to resign
and I think you can do that in a way
which still supports the party but makes
clear your own views your own principles
because of that so that's why I've
decided to leave this morning so you
resign because Pat McFadden was sacked
yes I think the decisions that were
given and I think the objections to the
statement that part made were were not
things that I could agree with I think
Pat gave a statement which is a vast
majority of leg party members and
British people would agree with and I
wasn't happy to see him sacked and the
reasons then that came out the reasons
that were given to endorse that second
were not things that I couldn't agree
with in addition to that to be honest
when I when I looked at the direction we
were taking in the reshuffle I just
thought the best thing for me to do as a
Labour MP loyal to the Labour pie wants
to see a Labour government was to have
the freedom to speak out from the back
benches about the things I think labour
should be doing and you know I think
it's nothing dishonorable about that I
think that's what we need more people to
do if they think that's the right thing
to do equally people want to serve
that's the right thing to do for them as
well but it's each and every MPs
decision and I hope you'll respect the
decision that I've made with respect you
are not being loyal to the party though
are you being loyal to Pat McFadden no I
wouldn't say that I think what I want to
see is a Labour government I want to see
the Labour Party in a position to become
a Labour government in future and if
there are serious doubts I've got about
the direction we're going in on certain
areas i think it is my duty to make
clear my own views on that I've got my
own mandating my own constituency my own
people to represent within that too and
I think that's important you know that
the party structures they're not just
entirely about the leadership and the
positions taken there about individual
MPs and if those MPs don't feel
they can honorably be on the front bench
than the honorable thing to do is to
resign so what's fundamentally changed
since you thought it was a good idea to
accept the job back in September apart
from Pat McFadden being attacked I still
I'm still pleased i took that job back
in September I think what was clear then
was there was an attempt to make a
broad-based as wide as possible at a
shadow administration as could be and
when Jeremy sent an olive branch to lots
of us who didn't vote for him I think
the honorable thing to do then was to
accept that and become part of that
shadow government but clearly that's not
worked out to anyone's advantage or its
felt that way and I think looking at
what is now required that's clearly
going to be a more disciplined if you
like more coherent message on foreign
defense policies I don't object at all
to the leaders right to do that if the
position that will be taking is laid pie
is not one that I'm entirely comfortable
with then I don't think I could be part
of not giving him long though happier to
settle into the job X Factor contestants
get longer than that well I'm not sure
where that's the case anymore but look
it's all about the decisions that have
taken not the time skill that they are
taking on this clearly being a big
change in the labor of print bench
yesterday late last night when those
decisions came out and I don't think
being true to my own conscience I could
have said that I think those decisions
are the right ones to make and so I just
felt I couldn't continue and I didn't
discuss that with anyone else other than
with my wife this morning I sent a
letter of resignation I tried to make
clear be very dignified and reasonable
with jeremy's to the reasons I thought I
couldn't continue and indeed to praise
him on the areas where I think he said
and done the right thing but if I don't
feel it's the right thing for me to do I
need people to respect that decision
it's he the right man to lead the Labour
Party he's got a huge Monday to lead
late by ona do not like nine waited but
clearly we've had four candidates will
leader we've all voted for different
people so we're not going to pretend we
didn't vote for different people just a
relatively short period of time moving
on but I think what we need in the party
let's be clear I'm not entirely
convinced to be honest that any of the
leadership candidates could have
honestly said they've been in ass would
be in a strong position to make the leg
part win the next general election had
any of them won I think that means that
we need a serious and quite difficult
debate about where labor is going and
there
limitations reasonable limitations that
are put on people who run the front
bench and if I don't want to accept
those limitations i want the chance to
speak about the economy about welfare
about foreign policy as well as
transport which is what I was a shadow
minister before if I want that freedom I
think I've got to do the honorable thing
and do it from the back benches oh that
was a politician sense and that's not
what I asked you I asked you whether mr.
Corbin was the right man to lead the
Labour Party but he hasn't mandates lead
load party and I said and I said at the
time that it's not that that's not what
I'm asking you so if I asked you a third
time would you say the same thing again
well he's the right man because he's the
man who won the election I think that's
what are you thinking the right man I'm
not much I didn't vote for Jeremy I've
never I've never denied that I different
foot forgery it's a public what do you
see the right man to leave the Labour
Party well I wouldn't have voted for him
and I didn't vote for him in the contest
but he is the right man because he has
the mandate to lead the Labour Party and
people like myself who are resigning
today we're not objecting I think to
that mandate we respect that Monday but
that doesn't mean we feel the right
thing for ourselves to do is to serve on
its front bench what about the other
front benchers what would you perhaps
say to them I'm thinking particularly if
people like I don't know Andy Burnham
well I think everybody has to make their
own decisions based on what they feel it
is best i think there's honor in leaving
and there's honor in staying and I think
you know trying to divide the party into
those two camps it's not a helpful thing
to do I know they're of colleagues might
have liked me to stay and I know there
are colleagues of mine who wished I
hadn't accepted a job in the first place
but I do what I think is best for my
area for myself as a Labour MP
representing those views and I'll always
put that first regard so what are the
colleagues may think about that so I'm
happy for everyone to make their own
decision on this and I don't I don't
object to anyone staying or indeed
leaving if they've done that after that
after I've made my decision today mr.
Reynolds will you sleep safer in your
bed knowing that Emily Thornberry is in
charge of your policies views on defense
well Jeremy is clearly one today a one
view to be coming from the senior
members of the the shadow cabinet on
defence policy clearly that is awkward
for some of us because it's different to
what official party policy is and young
we're going to resolve that it's about
having perhaps a proper process at
conference a decision that we decide
we're going to continue with our
existing policy or move to something
different but clearly I've got
objections to some of the things that
now becoming officially from a front
bench on that and again the only
honorable thing to do to respond to that
is to make sure you're able to speak
freely about what you think is right for
your area because of that but yeah Kevin
Jones who knows a lot about defense says
that she knows nothing about defense he
also said that the Deputy Leader Tom
Watson had serious reservations about
her being offered the job nevertheless
she was what do you think of that well
those are strong words I think you know
a lot of Labour MPs are comfortable with
the official policy of the leg party on
defense matters and that will be the
case at all levels of the party but
clearly there are different views on
this they've always been different views
stretching back really back to the 1950s
when this first became an issue when the
first labour government would come
Natalie took that decision to get us a
nuclear weapon in the UK and for us to
be a nuclear power there's always been a
split on this so it comes up time and
time again but clearly it's very
difficult but I understand why Jeremy
wants a defence secretary who has the
same view as him but obviously I'd like
him to try and understand where other
members with different views to him
coming from within the PLP to final
thought just before we let you go mr.
Reynolds looking at the lineup of the
shadow cabinet and the shadow ministers
as they stand today are they a good team
to perhaps lead the country come the
next election well it could be I think
nearly every member laid part will
probably regret the last few days have
been spent talking about a reshuffle
rather than about the flooding problems
rather than about the rail fare
increases and of course the
Conservatives problems that they've got
with the EU referendum so if we are able
to take on the Tories that would be a
good team doing that but I think what I
am worried about is we're giving the
wrong impression with some of the
decisions that we've made in this region
particularly on foreign policy and we
won't get a chance frankly to make that
argument for a fairer better Britain if
people are worried about our credentials
on defense and foreign policy great to
talk to you thanks for joining us on Sky
News